I'm here practising for the Rakahuri Rage,
a team mountain biking event
down at the Ashley River, on Sunday the 12th of March.
The Rakahui Rage is a six hour event
in which teams of 2-4 riders
compete in a relaxed and social atmosphere.
Riders, young and old
of all abilities, compete safely in
a fun environment.
You might wonder why I'm riding down here at
the Dudley Aquatic Centre.
Well, all proceeds from the event, go towards supporting
the Mainpower WaiSwim programme, which teaches
our kids to swim and be safe in the water.
So whether your a lycra-wearing speed freak
or a weekend warrior, there's a place in the
Rakahuri Rage for you. Get a team together
or your family and come join me on
Sunday 12th of March.
The race is open to all riders 12 years
and older with a variety of categories
to suit everyone and anyone.
Click on the link below to find out more and register.